ugh the holidays are finally upon us
which means it's the season for
cookies welcome to the holiday cookie
showdown with us your favorite buzzfeed
hosts hannah and joyce four amateur
bakers will compete in unique cookie
challenges in order to crown the
ultimate holiday baker let the
competition begin
[Music]
hi everyone it's joyce and hannah and
welcome back to our search for the best
holiday cookie maker today we'll
challenge our three remaining
contestants to create their best holiday
decorated cookie this baking competition
is sponsored by shipt the delivery
service making the holidays easier for
all home chefs now let's welcome back
our bakers
[Applause]
so happy to see you i made it to the
next round so i'm really excited hi
bakers and welcome back to the holiday
cookie showdown today you will be baking
a sugar cookie to look like an ugly
holiday sweater i love ugly holiday
sweaters i wear them all the time i'm
feeling a little bit nervous about this
challenge and again you'll be judged on
taste presentation and holiday essence
caroline since you won the last
challenge you'll have a slight advantage
of using this sweater cookie cutter to
cut your cookies
the other contestants will unfortunately
have to cut their cookies by hand that's
not going to be easy this is not an easy
shape to cut by hand i feel
really happy that i get this advantage
because i'm not great with
cutting
like lines well with a knife
but also
kind of a little restricted because
i won't really get to
make my own little designs and i feel
like we should warn you i'm really
intense about my holiday sweaters i own
about a thousand and we're really gonna
be scrutinizing these sweaters today you
know it's all about the look the flavor
and
a really ugly sweater again you have one
hour to complete your cookies starting
now
i'm feeling a little flustered because
we have a lot more to do with the same
amount of time
so i have to
mix the cookie dough freeze it bake it
decorate it within an hour are you
excited
feels so bad for you guys have you guys
cut shapes with
by hand i'm pretty good with a knife
i think maybe you should help us out
since we helped you try my best
i'm really excited because i love ugly
holiday sweaters i wear them all the
time and i love decorating the frosting
so i'm really excited to dive in and
make this cookie come to life
oh god
oh definitely did the wrong one whatever
they're gonna be super almondy
but um i think this is ready for the
fridge
it says
yeah yeah
have you guys ever made
royal icing before yeah
i have not so we'll see how this goes i
can teach you a little trick to make
sure it's uh
nice and tight when you pipe it one nice
trick nice and clumpy
oh my gosh
it depends if i get that cutter all
right let's see what's going on how's
everybody doing
[Music]
as joyce and hannah enter i'm
excited because i think that they're
going to come up to each of us and kind
of check in on what we're doing and then
i can kind of pick their brains a little
bit of what they're expecting
sugar
did you guys think you were gonna get
off that easy if you look behind you at
this mantel there are three jars of
candy
plot twist you gotta use one on your
cookie decoration
and make sure you don't overpower the
cookie because these are pretty intense
and you gotta get pretty creative to
incorporate these candies and you guys
have 30 minutes left so good luck bye
okay
now i have to decorate with candies i
got licorice bites i got sour strips
chewy fruit candies
i can't believe that i was making ugly
sweater cookies and now i have to use
some candies and i can't wait to see how
you guys use them
i'm kind of excited about it it's kind
of like
decorating gingerbread houses or
something with candies i'm thinking
about doing a
vaqueroja or a cowboy hat as a christmas
accessory to my little crop top sweaters
i don't really have a lot of sweaters
but i'm gonna make some like ugly crop
top sweaters oh my god
that says winter
you're so sweet oh my god
i have to make joyce's sweater i love
her sweater so much it kind of gives me
grinchy vibes and it's super glam and
cool
so i'm kind of freaking out because the
time is really cutting short and
um i have some plans in my head but they
they take a while to create put four
more in the oven and
i don't know what i'm doing wish for
good luck
okay
wow the glitter um is so cute
my icing is so runny
i saw there's a powdered sugar bag and i
don't think anyone else noticed but
there's a vanilla buttercream recipe on
the bag so this is my advantage i don't
think either of them notice they're
trying to do some royal frosting things
because we have meringue powder but it's
very temperamental and if the cookie's
warm it's going to turn into a glaze
i have these licorice bites that are
going to be perfect as the buttons for
the sweater i'm not going to use the
black ones because i just don't know if
anyone actually likes black licorice so
i'm hoping they don't ding me for not
using those because i'm trying to save
them you're welcome joyce and hannah i
don't want you to have a gross cookie
[Music]
oh my god
wait what
oh my god so one of my cookies had their
arm fall off so to remedy the issue i'm
just breaking off the other sleeve um
and making it a sleeveless sweater
[Music]
we did it
hey baker
and it's time to taste test how are you
feeling about the experience how did
making these
sweater cookies work out for you
that was intense yeah the time crunch
was a lot are we ready to try yeah okay
all right eliana
so i was very inspired and i made
joyce's sweater so this is a
deconstructed cookie oh my gosh
are you serious well good luigi these
are sugar cookies and i also made a
vanilla buttercream frosting you were
able to get a lot of texture so it looks
like knit should we taste yeah let's
taste
taste this is mighty convenient too
cheers
wow
it's baked really well mm-hmm
it's not overdone it's not burned yeah
it's like just barely golden on the
bottom
i love the hint of vanilla and i really
like how
um she incorporated the candy into the
buttons i think you played it a little
safe just using the red ones but i get
why you wouldn't use the black ones but
i think the black would have been a
bigger challenge to incorporate
i felt a little risky yeah
i wasn't sure it's disgusting
okay one two three
yay
i'm just excited that they could tell i
was really intentional to make it
special for them benji
come on down let's go i'm a little bit
worried because my candy is not as
prevalent as i would like it to be
ooh
this is giving me a very island
holiday i'm gonna say it's like a little
hawaiian shirt yeah let's see let's
start by tasting cheers cheers
mmm
it almost has a little lemon vibe
i purposely added a little bit more zest
because i just wanted to
switch it up a bit
i love the cowboy hats i love the block
of wood it makes me feel like i'm in a
log cabin one two three
thank you
i like that
i think i just wanted a little bit more
icing yeah
it did melt it was a hot cookie so it
turned into a glaze okay caroline let's
see your cookies bring it on down
wow
so
today i'm serving you the ugliest
sweaters that i could possibly come up
with yes
excellent awesome wow excellent
i'm getting a little more salt
i love salt yeah this is definitely
giving me the kind of shirts that i
would wear to a party i'm missing
like a layer of frosting or glaze
underneath the decoration i feel like
that helps the decoration pop even if it
was just like a little clear glaze
underneath it
three two one
the person with the most points today
was eliana congratulations
nacho park beautiful cookie
the next part's really tough it was a
one-point difference
for who's going home today um
unfortunately caroline
you are eliminated and i think that you
know as you're making more cookies for
the holidays know that you are still one
of the best bakers
you're an excellent baker
really enjoyed your cookies gross benji
bring it island
[Laughter]
thanks for tuning in to our second
episode of the holiday cookie showdown
and don't miss our next episode to see
who wins the finale
see you next time bye
[Music]